اكيد لا تزالله الاوضاع في كوسوفو غير
واضحه المعالم مع استمرار التوتر في
الاقليم الذي ترفض صربي الاعتراف
باستقلاله ومنذ العاشر من الشهر الجاري
بدا المواطنون الصرف شمال كسوفه في اقامه
عده حواجز على طرق حول مدينه تاميتروبيتشا
وفي داخلها متبدي لنا اطلاق النار مع شرطه
كوزوفو بعد اعتقال شرطي صربيا سابق على
خلفيه مزاع باعتدائي على ضباط الشرطه خلال
احتجاجا سابق واليوم اغلق في سلطات في
كوسوفي اكبر معبرين حدود مع صربيا وسطى
وتره بين البلدين اتى هذا بعد ما اقامه
محتجون الصلب في مدينه ميتروبيتشال منقسمه
عرقيا في شمال جديده على الطرق
نحو خمسين الف صربيه يعيشون في الاجزاء
الشماليه من كوسوفو ذات الاغلبيه
الالبانيه ويرفضون الاعتراف بدوله كوسوفو
او بحكومتها ينظرون الى بلغراد على انها
عاصمه لهم وتدعمهم في ذلك الصربيا التي
اعلنت قصب واستقلالها عنها عام 2008 وقد
دعى كل من الاتحاد الاوروبي والنيتو الى
ضبط النفس وقالت قوه حفظ السلام في بيان
نحط جميع الاطراف على مساعدتنا على بسط
الامن وضمان حريه الحركه
ومنع روايات المضلله من التاثير في عمليات
الحوار